foreign
is with us and is in Nashville hi Ann
how are you
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
um so student months are starting back
up pretty soon the interest rates on
those uh my husband and I have about 30
000 and our only other debt is the house
um we have four different accounts one
unsubscribed and three subsidized and I
know that student loans are simple
interest so I guess the interest accrued
can't continue to accrue interest
so should we be paying a income driven
repayment so that that gets our payments
lower so we can attack the principal and
then Circle back it doesn't change it at
all
no nope doesn't change at all all that
changes it is the amount you pay in
oh okay because the interest is charged
on your outstanding balance regardless
of how the outstanding balance was
achieved
even if we pay the the principal down if
you pay the principal down you've if you
pay down anything on the account that is
all it all becomes principal if you
don't pay it
so when you're doing income Basin and
you're not even covering the interest
you're increasing the principle
you're taking out a one pocket and
putting it in the other
it's still it's a dollar swap so no
you're better off what's your household
income
uh I think I take home 15 my husband
takes on 30. okay so 80 000 how fast
you're gonna pay off 30k
uh we're thinking two years I'm thinking
one
I'm thinking you need to quit going out
to eat and going on vacations because
the salad this Sallie Mae has been in
your life way too freaking long lady
yeah it's time to punch it in the face
thirty thousand out of eighty thousand
it's not realistic in your mind but it
is in my mind because I've watched
hundreds and hundreds thousands of
people do it over the last 30 years
but you're just still trying to figure
this out with math and I want you to get
pissed off at this situation and sick
and tired of being sick and tired and
sacrificed so deeply that your friends
think you've joined a cult
that's when you'll get out of debt
yeah the greater you're in you're not
going to fix this with math you're still
trying to fix it with your brain your
brain got you into this mess
your brain told you it was okay to
borrow to go to school
you there yeah you there yeah
yep yeah
okay hey I uh I I I can hear the words
you're using and the way you're
performing your sentences
um and uh the reason I could hear it is
I am a fellow nerd
yeah okay so I'm the nerd I can tell
offender I'm also the spender though I
know me too me too we're an unusual lot
we spend our nerds are unusual but the
but I could hear the nerd you're still
cranking the math
you're trying to figure out the way the
interest is calculated and use that as
somehow a shortcut to get out of debt
and what you need is 30 freaking
thousand dollars now
right that solves all your math problems
boom just like that oh yeah just
throwing a grenade yes throwing a
grenade in the middle of the swamp the
snakes go everywhere
and it's there's this intensity and
logic leaves and it's sacrifice and it's
this I'm I I like my freaking life
depends on it like my hair is on fire
and you the people that get out of debt
the fastest and actually the easiest are
the ones that do that
right activating this emotion
and that's what we're known for yep
well and that's and that's the progress
and because here's the deal I'm like you
can sacrifice to a level for two years
or you can sacrifice deeply for one year
you just cut it in half the sacrifice is
more intense but it's in a shorter
amount of time and then once it's done
oh yeah you have enough clothes in your
closet to make it a year you don't need
to buy anything else yep you work extra
all you do is work you cut off all your
stupid cable everything else you don't
need to be watching type of connections
you need to begin you need to be dad gum
getting your work done the crown the
crown I haven't heard Tiger King in
probably two years uh Yellowstone there
you go guilty pleasure Dave way to be
relevant there we go all right and um
well yeah and so um
I do want to see about that and on The
View
I'm sorry what Beth Dutton on The View
on The View the show The View wouldn't
that be great if you could get the
character Beth Dutton to go on The View
oh oh oh oh I don't want Yellowstone I
don't know what you're talking oh you
don't know no I don't know what you're
talking about all the Yellowstone fans
we're gonna talk a lot of his blinds
again that's that season we can talk
that but okay
okay uh but no but the point is like
when you're look when you're looking at
the math of her situation her and her
husbands
and you're used to living on 80 going
down to 50. it's very hard it's hard but
you do it for a year
and to your point it's that it's that
emotion there there's something
happening and the point is not the point
of the conversation is not is 12 months
magic it could be 14. it could be 11.
it's not the Magic Moment the point is
to increase the intensity
because that is the secret sauce this
gazelle intensity that's what we named
this debit card after the gazelle card
it's gazelle intensity from Proverbs
like the gazelle running from the
cheetah uh you're running for your life
and when you get that that's when your
life is transformed people there's
something that the great motivator let's
uh Les Brown used to say the and does
say still the your life changes when you
say I've
had it not when I figured out the math
and I tried I'm a math nerd so I can
hear math nerd a mile away I know I know
nerd speak I can hear it and uh I'm the
same way always trying to figure out a
way sharing my wife uh and my wife would
always say which came in the scamming
your scheme is going to be trying to
figure out easy way just do the work
just roll up your sleeves and do the
work stop trying stop it stop it just
yeah just get after it and there's this
get it thing there's the thing there
that's going on and um and then and you
know then you pick up didn't she say
she's a nurse no I don't know I think
she'd pick up extra all kinds of extra
hours you know because there's all kinds
of if you're in the medical field good
Lord you can work all you want and uh
because there's a shortage of everything
if you're in the teaching field there's
a shortage of everything if you're in
the First Responders world you're
there's a shortage of everything you can
work all you want and uh and then some
you work more than you can physically do
and and just go crazy for a short period
of time then you got the whole rest of
your life to be free
but the stinking student loan will hang
around like a disease man
you can't if it won't you can wander in
but you cannot wander out you gotta bust
your way out fighting clawing machetes
axes Bazookas I mean you got a good you
got violence inflict of violence on the
situation emotionally and that's that is
the secret folks that's the big deal
everybody's thinking I'm going to
refinance my credit card debt from 18 to
14 and that will get no won't help you
same stupid thinking that got you in the
first place